[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
This is I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'm at the community lounge.
This is where anybody can swing
by and meet up with old friends
or make new ones.
I'm going to go find some
certification alumni to talk
to them about the program.
Hey, Maria.
Hi, everyone.
How you doing?
SPEAKER 1: Doing good.
How are you?
SPEAKER 2: Awesome.
SPEAKER 3: Really Great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Ha ha.
I'm sitting here with
[? Henry, ?] [? Ashesh, ?]
and [? Somia. ?] And they're
all alumni in the certification
program.
I'd like to ask you just a
few things about the program
if that's OK.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Sure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's start
with, how did you get involved?
What made you want
to get certified?
SPEAKER 1: So actually
before in Indonesia, they
have a scholarship.
So they give out the 500
scholarship for the people
to take with the [INAUDIBLE]
and certifications.
And I register on that one.
And I got it.
And then after that, I
tried certifications.
And yeah--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So your
path was from scholarships
to certification.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [? Ashesh? ?]
SPEAKER 2: OK, so if
you see the reason
I went for the certification.
In our professional life,
we strive for few things.
One of them is to prove
the worth to ourselves.
And second is to prove
our worth to others.
So to proving worth to
ourselves we go for a benchmark.
We try to achieve it.
So for me, that certification
was a benchmark,
a milestone achieved.
And once I have achieved that
there is only one way that
is to go for something higher.
Right?
So this is one reason to
prove myself, the worth,
so that I can go for
more higher things.
So certification was
a commitment to me,
to myself, to go far in
search of more knowledge.
And second thing is to
prove worth to others.
So if you saw even
you go for the job,
there are various phases.
There are interviews.
There are tests and everything.
But the first phase is
always the qualification.
What degrees do you hold?
What certifications do you hold?
If you don't cross that
door, there's no point.
I mean, you might be a very
good programmer or something.
But if you don't have the
initial key to that door--
so to have a certification,
you are always
have a key to open a door.
So that was the other thing
which I went certification for.
So in short, to gain
confidence and to be job ready.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
And [? Somia? ?]
SPEAKER 3: So I've been
working on Android since 2010.
So it's been eight years now
with Android as a developer.
I started with Android 1.6.
And I've done various
application in Android
at different levels.
Play Store based
applications, a lot
of enterprise applications
in the last three,
four years, and
things like that.
But I think what
was the pusher, what
pushed me to do the
certification was probably
that--
you know like [? Ashesh ?]
said, there's a benchmark
or there's a standard
with the certification.
And after working for
so long in Android,
worked on various
kinds of applications,
how do you differentiate
yourself from the others.
That was a
differentiation factor.
So I remember about
two years back, there
was a conference
in Google where I
asked about the certification.
And they said, yes, we are going
to roll out the program soon.
And so I registered with
the community groups.
And I got the email.
So I was more than
happy to try it.
It actually is already--
what do you see here, 360 degree
view on what your experience
is, a certification.
It judges you on a lot
of skills, not just
one core skill.
You need to talk.
360 degrees of your skills
are being mapped there.
So that was a great way
to get that done actually.
So that's how I got into it.
And I'm happy that
I achieved it also.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
Can each tell me one thing
that has been helpful
in your career because
of certification?
SPEAKER 3: Sure.
So actually in my
current organization,
we now have a team of
about 20 mobile developers,
mobile team more or less.
And what I noticed was we had
the support of the management
for conducting various
certifications and things
like that.
But when we did
the certification,
and I told my team
that see, I did this.
And it was cool.
And it gave a
validation to the team
also that how we're doing this.
And after that, very quickly, we
have almost 10 team members now
who are certified already.
So that was a big boost,
energizer to them too.
You know, from a team lead
to the rest of the team
saying that, oh,
you should do this.
And then that has worked out
very positively for them.
SPEAKER 2: So we had to
talk to them about exposing
our internal APIs.
And then our boss
had to survey them.
So this was the one
thing which motivated--
like when I was getting
into Android, at that point
in time, I thought, OK, I
will try to make the Android
app in-house for my company.
But the certification
was not there.
So I was also a little
hesitant to ask my boss
to give this job to
me because the app
matters are such financially.
But once I got
the certification,
and I told my boss, he
was very happy about it.
And of course he
was quite confident.
So now I have developed two
Android apps for my company
in-house.
So we have more
control over the apps,
especially since
I'm working already.
I know the back-end
and everything.
And our consumers also
get something more robust
and something more
user friendly.
So the certification
helped me to gain
the confidence of my boss and
to move my career in Android app
development.
SPEAKER 1: Before I took
the certifications whenever
I applied to a company, I always
chose the Android app developer
job.
And then they always give me the
interview for an iOS developer
job.
Then I try the certifications.
And then after I get
certified, it naturally
just knocked them
to their senses
that, OK, I'm
certified by Google.
So then they gave
me more chances.
They gave me chances for
the interview, for the test.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Otherwise
before, they just
gave me the test for iOS.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you all
so much for sharing your story
with me today.
If you'd like to learn
more about certification,
head on over to
g.co/dev/certification.
I'm Timothy Jordan
and this is I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]